citizens of the reject Nation this may
already be my favorite koi's comic
Corner because this is the one where I
get to say a sentence I never thought
I'd say anywhere but my dreams Hugh
Jackman is coming back as Wolverine in
Deadpool 3 not only are we getting
another version another moment another
experience of Wolverine not only are we
finally getting Deadpool in the MCU but
we're getting those two beautiful babies
together we are gonna make sweet sweet
Weapon X love with that logo we're gonna
dive into all of that we're gonna talk
about the possible plot I got some ideas
of what this might be we're gonna talk
about what version of Wolverine I think
this might be because I don't
necessarily think it's one we've seen
before I'm gonna talk about cameos we
could expect if it is the plot that I
think it is we've got a lot of details a
lot of breadcrumbs a lot of Easter eggs
leaning towards that Journey how that
all ties into the greater MCU going
forward because I do not think this
September 24 release date is a
coincidence so please do leave a like on
this video leaving a like helps me know
you like this it's well named it's right
there it's got a thumbs up which makes
me feel good about myself also please do
follow me on Tick Tock I make a lot of
videos over there I've made four about
this very subject but I haven't revealed
a lot of these thoughts yet because I
wanted I wanted to bring it to you first
but I do a lot of talking over on the
ticks and the talk so please follow me
on Tick Tock helps me know and well it
helps the studios know basically it's
for the people I want the people to know
that you guys like follow me let's dive
into it
[Music]
all right so we're gonna start off with
just pure hype if I don't get this out
of the way now we will we will have a
hard time later on Hugh Jackman being
back as Wolverine is something I always
wanted but didn't want and I I know that
sounds strange I wanted it but I didn't
in that Downey Jr Chris Evans and Hugh
Jackman I think are the three characters
who are most embodied by their actors
that also had the best complete arcs I
would change nothing about the journey
we went on with Iron Man top to bottom I
would change nothing about how things
landed with Chris Evans in his entire
Arc yes I would change X-Men Origins
Wolverine but I would not change it at
the cost of losing Logan and I think
that's how Hugh Jackman felt as well and
that he didn't want to lose the
Integrity of how Logan ended with the
perfect swan song for his perfect
Wolverine I think the beauty of
everything is now we're living in a
multiversal era we can have our cake and
eat it too and that we can have our
Logan and our Wolverine as potentially
separate entities so this is the only
way I have no single regrets about Hugh
Jackman coming back there is nothing
holding me from being fully excited you
give me a buddy cop movie with a fish
out of water Deadpool a feral R-rated
Wolverine you bring Hugh Jackman back
for one last ride this is exactly
exactly what we've only dreamed of and
the Multiverse brought us this as well
as the timing of the fox and Marvel
merger now this video is going to be in
a slightly different order than the
usual comic Corner because much like
Deadpool it's confusing with continuity
and it probably involves cable and
therefore time travel so we are going to
tease where I think they're going then
we'll get into the why and the details
of how we got there so at the top I'm
gonna let you know at the end I've seen
your comments we will be given comic
recommendations I could do an hour on
just Deadpool comic recommendations but
Greg was like if you give them
76 recommendations they won't read them
and I did I sent him 76 recommendations
he was like cool you can do three and I
was like maybe four he's like no no
three and he he runs things he's just
gonna edit it out so you're getting some
wrecks at the end so with everything we
know so far I do think this is going to
be pulling from the number one selling
Deadpool comic of all time which is
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe and I
also think due to where Deadpool 2 left
off with the Disney Fox merger with the
Multiverse established and The Saga this
deep into the Multiverse with the
release date being September a mere
three months from 2025 with the
announcement of Wolverine with what the
filmmakers have said with the change of
the writers with the R rating with
everything I think we've been told this
my dear viewers is going to be Deadpool
kills the fox Universe now you've
probably heard people theorize this
before or something akin to this a lot
of people have theorized Deadpool kills
the Marvel universe as something that
was going to happen you want to check
some tapes you might notice a certain
person in a chimichanga shirt said about
five and a half years ago he was the
first one he really thought Sandy had it
with Rob live felt the creator of
Deadpool so he might have been one of
the first to say it there's no way of
knowing a lot of people have the same
great idea at the same time but I do
know I was one of the very first to
suggest Deadpool killing the fox
Universe because I did talk with Rob
liefeld about it very very very long
time ago and then again we did talk
about it in the lockdown what's been
interesting is I think this story has
changed and developed over the course of
time because the way this merger is gone
I think the best thing to happen to
Deadpool one was that Ryan Reynolds
worked on it for 10 years I think the
best thing to happen to Deadpool 3 is
the fact that we had a fox Marvel merger
happen in the middle of a multi-billion
dollar franchise that is Deadpool only
one character was getting carried over
while Marvel was simultaneously setting
up their Multiverse Saga and then the
world stopped I do think there might be
a benefit to this weird two-year Gap
that coincides with the five-year blip
that coincides with one of the biggest
multimedia mergers of all time because I
honestly think we wouldn't have been
able to do Deadpool kills the fox
Universe without the rights expiring in
2025. so what I think is going to be
really interesting is this movie comes
out in September of 2024. this follows
the Thunderbolts Deadpool being a
thunderbolt I do think that is a perfect
place for a post-credits scene perhaps
the first official Deadpool appearance
in the MCU being in a post-credits scene
of thunderbolts and it's really
interesting because this not only comes
out after Thunderbolts again at that
post credit scene but this if you
remember in that giant lineup for phase
six there were a lot of spaces we saw
Fantastic Four which appeared to be the
kickoff of phase six but there was a
fall 2024 slot this movie right here may
be the first film the beginning the
kickoff of phase six which I do think is
going to lead to a lot of mutant and
this is only three months only one movie
removed from them being able to cast
mutants in the MCU this is right there
around the corner what better way to
kick off casting mutants in the MCU than
cleaning your slate and what better
character to do that with than the one
that represents Fox so cleanly who do
you think when you think X-Men I've said
it before and I'll say it again I really
really enjoy the X-Men movies but
they're Brian Singer mutant movies we
didn't really get a lot of X-Men movies
they also were Wolverine in the X-Men
movies all of that has been a point of
contention for me because I love me some
X-Men as much as I love Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine again I think he's one of the
greatest casting choices of all time I
always wanted X-Men I think they're
going to learn that lesson and give us
X-Men movies but in the meantime when I
think Fox when I think the X-Men I think
Hugh Jackman Wolverine so you've got the
perfect Pinnacle representing all that
is the fox mutant you've also got a
character that is a fourth wall breaking
self-aware only character up until she
helped down the MCU character that's
aware they're in a movie aware they're
in something based off a comic the
fourth wall breaking mixed with Hugh
Jackman coming back representing all of
fox cleaning the Slate for 2025 all of
that timing lines up beautifully and
that is a huge reason I think they're
going to be doing this kills the fox
Universe palette cleanser for all of us
in addition the writers changing and
getting Rhett Reese and Paul wernick
back I do think that might be them
wanting to do this from the beginning
and getting that back because of all
these circumstances but also the quotes
about this being a fish out of water
story and a bromance now Sean Levy
directed Real Steel Ryan Reynolds good
friends with Hugh Jackman I think the
combination once they brought on Sean
Levy a lot of us theorized that meant we
could get Wolverine Sean Levy said it as
much that's what he wanted saying quote
what we want to do is to fold it all in
together and make a big fat Bromance
sandwich of the movie because the world
wants the Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds
movie he said that months ago I think it
was the combination of Ryan pestering
you plus Sean Levy coming back to direct
with their relationship with Real Steel
I think that was the thing that finally
launched in and then the writers also
said quote it's a marriage between Fox
and Disney it's two different universes
and it's not easy but it's also a
wonderful Challenge and you know high
class problems be able to merge those
those worlds also having said it's quote
a wonderful opportunity for a fish out
of water story Deadpool is a lunatic at
the center of a movie to drop a lunatic
into a very sane world it's straight
butter it's gonna be really fun those
are the quotes we had before the Hugh
Jackman thing was launched but locked in
those are the quotes we knew about the
flavor of this movie The the reason I
think we're going to get this
combination of stories not just because
it's one of the best selling comics of
all time not just because it's a paling
cleanser and where it lines up in the
schedule but because I do think that
gives you some closure to make Deadpool
R-rated so what I think this is going to
do is go back to Deadpool 2. it's going
to start with Deadpool in the fox
Universe he's going to be living his
day-to-day life he might be doing some
time Turner hijinks I would love for
this to kick off right where the
post-credits scene did in that
continuity in Deadpool 2 he's using the
time Turner to clean up a lot of fun
Ryan Reynolds he thinks he gets rid of
Green Lantern he gets rid of X-Men
Origins Wolverine he even fights a
bygone Wolverine that's why I think
we're getting a different Wolverine than
the one in Logan in Logan we've got a
perfect bow of a story in X2 we could go
back and grab that guy and it'd be a
displaced time Wolverine or we could get
a completely different variant Wolverine
and I guarantee you within five minutes
Ryan Reynolds is gonna make him put on
that yellow and brown suit I guarantee
you because of this movie because the
Dynamics we're finally gonna get a comic
accurate Hugh Jackman Wolverine and I
think that visual is going to very much
illustrate this isn't Logan this isn't
the Wolverine we've known for all these
movies it is still Hugh Jackman acting
as eyeballs out being the perfect
Wolverine we've always wanted but it's
going to be very clear it's not the
Wolverine we've had and that's the
beauty of this Multiverse Saga it's all
the things we want but right over here
without sacrificing the Integrity of the
performance and allowing an R-rated
Wolverine if you think about it as far
back as X2 the Berserker rage was still
very PG-13 they had to cut around it we
then got Logan we finally got the
violence but now we get the perverse
humor of Deadpool mixed with the
violence of Logan all because we can
make this a fresh take on Hugh Jackman's
version of Wolverine I think that's what
they're gonna do so I think we're gonna
go back to Deadpool 2 he's going to be
using the time Turner going through
things maybe they'll put that baby
Hitler scene back in and we're gonna be
seeing a lot of fox cameos in the X-Men
vein I would love personally to see Anya
Taylor Joy get to play Magic one last
time I would love to see you know maybe
two colossuses we have Cudmore as well
as the guy who played him in Deadpool I
would love to see some of the cameos
that we got like we did in Deadpool 2.
throughout the opening of this film and
people are gonna go like oh right
Deadpool the audience is gonna think
this is Deadpool so it ties into X-Men
we get that Comfort we we feel nostalgic
seeing I doubt Jennifer Lawrence will
come back but maybe we get nostalgic
seeing these characters pop back up in
the realm we're used to and that's the
you know first 20 minutes and then while
traveling through time I think that's
when he meets a different Wolverine and
maybe he doesn't recognize him there's a
lot of fun comic book story lines you
could play with there maybe they go to
Alpha flight maybe we get some original
Weapon X stuff there's a lot to play
with there but then using those time
travel hijinks and setting up this new
Wolverine it turns into a them fighting
before they Team Up movie that is every
comic book that is so many tropes your
characters have to fight before they
team up that's how it goes we've heard
this is fish out of water I think that's
the third act in Marvel we've heard this
is team up buddy cop movie that's where
I think we get into the second act where
now that they've fought in a brutal
blood-soaked R-rated Battle of healing
and Berserker rage we then see them to
team up and what I think happens is we
then meet Chris Evans and Chris Evans
comes up and you're waiting for either
the shield you're waiting for a moment
of pure you know Captain America
Integrity maybe a speech maybe he calls
him James Howlett and you're expecting
like a World War II moment a throwback
to when they serve together and then he
flames on and you realize that oh right
we're in the fox Universe this bait and
switch with Chris Evans and then we have
to take him out because we find out that
an incursion event is coming which has
already been set up in multiple movies
especially most recently the Multiverse
Madness where an incursion event occurs
you have to take out one of the planets
to save the rest in order to save a
Galaxy they both die if they Collide but
if you can take one out you can save
billions of lives there's an entire
storyline in the comic books called
secret orbs where basically there's an
incursion of it where these worlds are
colliding and there's this super group
called The Illuminati which we also have
already met in the Multiverse of Madness
they were just set up in a different
array basically has to make these really
hard decisions this is all a precedent
we've already met all this in the MCU it
would be very easy the especially after
we meet Reed Richards to have this
Illuminati have to decide they need
someone to do the job no one else wants
to do Deadpool's a mercenary and
Wolverine's the best he is at what he
does I think there will be an
opportunity for them to save more lives
Logan getting to keep his Integrity of
having to kill for all the right wrong
reasons and Deadpool enjoying being a
mercenary he's got a heart of gold but
he's definitely a killer taking out
these characters I think starting with
human torch Chris Evans and then maybe
going right into Michael B Jordan's
Chris Evans and then maybe we get
Nicholas Cage's Ghost Rider then maybe
we get Idris Elba and we think it's
going to be heimdell but then someone
remembers oh right Idris Elba was
briefly in Ghost Rider too there's a lot
of really cool opportunity to play with
expectations through the second act of
this film going into the third Act of
this film and we see us finally
eviscerate the fox Universe through one
of the most bloody experiences of buddy
copton we could hope for and then when
Deadpool lands in the MCU maybe either
Wolverine has to sacrifice himself maybe
huge meets the new version maybe it's uh
you know a Daphne Keen reference maybe
we don't actually see Wolverine because
remember they can't cast him until 2025
we got three months to go maybe a
post-credit scene sets up the new
Wolverine but I do think there will be
an ending that is the passing of the
torch and I think there will be a very
funny death of Logan I I think at this
time it'll end humorously I don't think
they'll kill him sadly twice I think
Logan is the saddest we'll get so they
won't try to compete with that I think
there will be a humorous Death of
Wolverine setting up passing the torch
very officially to the new Wolverine to
come starting three months from then in
2025 and I think that is going to be
where we get into the Fish Out of Water
Deadpool scenario where he because he
knows he's from Another Universe because
he's been tasked from the MCU to take
out the fox Universe because he's been
assigned aware there's multiple
universes that's how he can break the
fourth wall in ours that's how he can be
the only R-rated character that's how
when you put Deadpool in the X-Men later
or The Avengers later or maybe even in
the Thunderbolt he swears it gets
bleeped because he's someone from
another Universe our universe the MCU
the 616 they sometimes call it it's very
messy with continuities they count a lot
of different things one nine nine nine
nine nine or six one six that Universe
can't handle an R-rated character like
Deadpool so that would bleep but in his
mind and in his movies he could still be
R-rated so when you fold him in put him
in the MCU have that fourth wall break
have the awareness of the other
universes he just destroyed with
Wolverine have us finally get that team
up we've always wanted and have us clean
up the continuity of all the messiness
of fox have that clean up Xavier being
in Multiverse of Madness have that
cleanup Pietro you know he's gonna kill
a character named Ralph boner you know
he's gonna do it he's gonna enjoy it you
know all of that can get cleaned up very
beautifully and give us the mutant Saga
to come in 2025 this starts phase six
have it end 22 years of fox continuity
in Canon with the right characters to do
it have Hugh Jackman back as Wolverine
have Ryan Reynolds start his MCU tenure
with Deadpool kills the fox universe
that's what I'd do it'd be awesome let
me give you some comic recommendations
so I said I'd give you guys comic
recommendations at the end in addition
to of course Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe it's written by Cullen Bunn it
is one of the most successful I think it
is to date the most successful Deadpool
comic of all time Deadpool goes around
and has to kill everyone in Marvel it is
a very bloody good time I would also
recommend in that same vein after it did
so well they did a pseudo sequel called
Deadpool killustrated it is basically
Deadpool in every classic folk tale
killing everything so like he kills the
way Lynn Moby Dick he kills Jack of Jack
and the Beanstalk and it's this really
beautiful stunningly Illustrated take of
Deadpool just mowing down all of your
favorite fairy tales and I think that
could be something they incorporate but
it's also just a really good comic and
then finally all of this was about
Deadpool kills the fox Universe if they
don't to that story I want them to do my
favorite Deadpool Arc of all time I have
two favorites one of them is Spider-Man
Deadpool team up we'll talk about that
in another video because that also might
be coming but my favorite of all time
that's Deadpool Centric without Spidey
is is The Good the Bad and the Ugly and
that is a story in North Korea where
Wolverine Captain America and Deadpool
are doing a rescue mission at a
concentration camp for these these
people that were were kidnapped and and
put in this camp and basically force-fed
Deadpool's DNA and they're rotting and
mutating and they're turning into
different versions of the X-Men and
Wolverine and cap go way back to World
War II and then Deadpool is serious for
once there's moments of levity but it's
a really dark story that shows you the
heart of Deadpool the reason I like
Deadpool 1 so much is you see that
Deadpool's a character that wears a mask
to hide his face to protect you from
being grossed out not his identity and
this comic does that it shows you the
heart and the soul of Deadpool if they
don't do Deadpool kills the fox Universe
I'd love to see something like that with
Hugh Jackman Wolverine as well as
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds maybe even
Captain America screw it bring back
Chris Evans is the one way I want Chris
Evans back all right I'd recommend The
Good the Bad and the Ugly Deadpool
killustrated and Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe enjoy those Comics let
me know what you thought of them let me
know what you thought of this video let
me know if there's anything in this plot
you want me spelled out more if you want
me to talk about some Spider-Man
Deadpool comics just leave a comment
below let me know what you thought of
this idea and I'll see you next time I
can't believe this exists guys 2024 I'm
gonna be insufferable all nine months
just talk about this in fact from now on
Good Luck Channel
[Music]